ce dimanche 23 septembre devant la tour
eiffel 25 mille coureurs se sont donné
rendez vous pour participer à la 41e
édition du paris versailles
au programme de cette course mythique 16
km entre le monument parisien le château
versailles en passant par la forêt de
meudon à parcours inchangé depuis 1979
et qui séduit toujours autant les
sportifs c'est la première que je le
ferai en plus et est franchement c'est
super parce qu'en plus des courses en
ligne ça devient de plus en plus rares
ou encore d'un point à un autre et le
décor extras dans la soirée avec la
nature l'enchaînement des bosses ça
permet justement de faire un peu la
différence au niveau de ceux qui sont
plus résistants aux nues meilleur dans
les côtes
le vainqueur est lui burundais abraham
niyonkuru s'est détaché dans le sprint
final pour s'imposer en cinquante et une
minutes et trente et une secondes devant
le français gétigné g dames ou médaille
[Musique]
chez les féminines c'est l'éthiopienne
chaque acquerra qui l'emportent à 22 ans
la sportive franchi la ligne d'arrivée
en 1h01 et 35 secondes
elle devance la française laurie
lindekens de deux minutes tout ce beau
monde devra se retrouver l'année
prochaine pour une 42e édition du paris
versailles